katia bonjour alors vous avez a donc
suivi cette conférence de presse qu
est-ce qu on peut en retenir
alors il faut rappeler qu'il y à deux
accords le premier qui concerne luce
personnels hospitaliers non médecin il
s'accompagne d'une enveloppe de 7,5
milliards d'euros on vient d'en parler
mais il ya également un second accord
celui ci est destiné aux médecins
hospitaliers et cette fois-ci long
l'abeille de 450 millions il comprend
treize mesures dont une augmentation de
la prime pour les médecins hospitaliers
qui s'engagent à ne travailler que dans
l'hôpital public sans dépassement
d'honoraires
il comprend également au titre des
mesures une revalorisation de la grille
salariale mais pour les syndicats de
médecins et bien le compte n'y est pas
alors certes deux syndicats ont bien
signé la snam hp et lienne ph mais pour
les autres vraiment il ne s'agit pas de
ça il faut continuer à faire entendre
les revendications
même ceux qui ont signé ont estimé que
l' enveloppe n'était pas suffisante il
ne s'attendait plutôt à quelques
milliards et non pas à 450 millions
alors quels sont les points de désaccord
notamment le salaire d'embauché pour les
jeunes médecins les gardes qui ne seront
pas revalorisés les heures
supplémentaires même chose elles ne sont
pas traitées à leur jeu juste mesure
dans cet accord du ségur donc ce matin à
les syndicats qui y sont opposés à cette
signature qui sont par exemple action
aux praticiens hôpital la muse et jeunes
médecins ont tenu une conférence de
presse pour parler des modalités
d'action parce que au-delà du ségur et
bien ils comptent bien faire entendre
leurs revendications pour pour rallonger
cette enveloppe alors ils seront
évidemment dans la rue demain mais ils
vont continuer à porter leurs
revendications pour obtenir satisfaction
merci katia pour toutes ces précisions